[MUSIC PLAYING]
Congratulations.
You've got a great,
new social application
that seems to be all the rage.
But you keep getting reports
that when users download
a new horde of
profile thumbnails,
the application crawls
along and feels slow.
My name is Colt McAnlis,
and even though you're
in a managed memory environment,
improperly using memory
can still kick off a load
of performance problems.
And allocating too many
objects in a short time frame
is a clear problem that
you should be aware of.
You have to remember that
the memory heap in Android
is segmented up
into separate spaces
based upon what type of
allocation is occurring.
And as allocations in
any of the spaces grow,
a GC event can be
kicked off in order
to make more room for
future allocations.
And depending on what
runtime you're using,
GC events can be
stop-the-world events,
meaning that any managed code
that's in flight on any thread
will stop.
The GC event will run, and
then only when it's done
will execution continue.
Now, halted execution
from a GC event
isn't really normally a
noticeable performance problem.
However, a lot of them,
occurring over and over
and over and over again, can
quickly eat up your frame time.
The more time you're
spending doing GCs,
the less time you have to
do other interesting stuff,
like rendering or
streaming audio.
Now, the number one
cause of GC cascades
like this is something
called memory churn.
Effectively, memory churn is
when a high number of objects
are allocated and
potentially freed
in a really small
amount of time.
You know, like that new
function that you've just
written that checks if a
movie director for a new movie
has been swayed by public
opinion yet, and, if not,
allocates a horde
of social posts
that pushes them up
to the inter-tubes.
Yeah.
Just like that.
First off, you should calm down.
This actually isn't
really that big of a deal.
Secondly, the quick
allocation of so many objects
effectively pollutes
the recently allocated
objects space with a flood
of reserved memory blocks.
Once you reach a threshold
of reserved memory,
a GC event will be kicked
off to clear up space.
Even if the memory allocations
are tiny, the volume of them
creates pressure on your heap
to kick off more GC events
over time, which can eat
into your precious frame time
and cause the user to
notice a performance
difference since
you'll eventually
be slipping past your
16-millisecond rendering
barrier.
Now, fixing these
types of problems
are actually pretty
straightforward.
To start, if you're noticing,
in the Memory Monitor,
that you're getting
a flood of GC events
in a very short time frame, then
this points to a high chance
that you've got a lot of
memory churn going on here.
You can then dig a little deeper
using the Allocation Tracker
tool in Android Studio
to identify any areas
where you may be seeing a horde
of similar object types coming
from roughly the same call stack
in a very short period of time.
This is a classic sign
of memory thrashing,
and easy to see that
it's the right place
to start your investigation.
And once you've
identified the culprit,
it's time to start
moving around your code
to fix the problem, which itself
is also pretty straightforward.
For example, make sure that
you're not allocating objects
in inner loops for
obvious reasons.
Try to push those allocations
outside of the loop
or avoid them
entirely if you can.
The same advice goes
for allocating objects
in the onDraw functions
of your views.
This is, effectively, the
same problem as an inner loop.
Any time the screen
needs to be redrawn
or an animation is
occurring, you'll
end up with calls
to these functions
every single frame,
which can quickly add up,
adding pressure to your heaps.
Now, for situations where
you can't remove the need
to create new objects
in these scenarios,
consider using an
object pool pattern.
Effectively, you have
an object pool that
allocates a group of objects.
And rather than having your
code go to the heap each time,
it instead grabs available
objects from your memory pool.
Of course, the downside
to this pattern
is that you're now responsible
for freeing objects back
to the memory pool when
you're done with them, which
means that for
high-churn objects,
there's going to be a bit
of a mental overhead needed
to properly manage when
these objects are created
and destroyed.
But that's just the
tip of the iceberg.
The rest of the Android
Performance Patterns content
has other great tips and
tricks to solve and address
these problems.
And don't forget to join our
Google+ community for other
insights from fellow developers.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]